eric fetty to the mound six and nine
with a 5.08 era his last start fp came
against this very mets team and they
pretty much
lit him up last time at city field
jonathan vr hits the first pitch through
the hole for a base hit and here we go
again jonathan villar had hits in each
of his last four at bats last night he's
now had hits in five straight and he's
got a base hit on the first pitch of
this game here's nimmo one for four last
night
2-2 coming to nimmo and he rips it
through the hole there's a base hit vr
will turn second he'll go on to third
and the mets have runners at the corners
with nobody out so they don't shift
against nemo and he pulls the ball right
through that hole first and third and
nobody out and here's francisco lindor
it took an over five last night nimmo at
first three and two nobody out not
running and lendore finds the hole
that's a base hit and the mets take the
lead
vr is in nimmo goes first to third three
straight hits to start the game lindor
gets the base hit to put the mets on top
so a run is in after three straight hits
and here's alonso still nobody out
and pete slugs one toward the gap in
right center field soto goes back and
makes the catch tagging at third is
nimmo he'll come in to score and it's
two nothing new york
[Applause]
lendore takes off ruiz the throw down
lindor just in there ahead of the tag
from luis garcia
garcia pointed to his dugout immediately
telling davey martinez to take a look
and maybe they did get him
he's out
the first big league caught stealing for
k bear ruiz
and there's marcus stroman's numbers and
as i've mentioned he is the ace of this
staff that nine and 12 record is
not indicative of how he's pitched his
first half of the year in 19 starts he
takes the ball every day by the way he
was six and seven with a 2.74
second half of the season nine starts
he's three and five with the 3.06 he has
been solid lane two for three career
against strowman
elaine thomas
yet another knock
leadoff single here in the bottom half
of the first
and bill with a half swing it's in there
for a call third strike
he didn't swing but it was in the strike
zone and strowman has the second out
and hernandez lifts one out to left
center
angling in his nemo
side retired so strowman you had to use
25 pitches to get through that first
inning but he protects a two-nothing
lead after one now baez with 26 home
runs on the year leading off
bias drives one to deep center field
back goes thomas to the warning track
and it's out of here javi bias gets eric
fetty again
took him deep at city field last week
and bias homers against him one more
time
number 27 for bias his fifth is a met
and it's three-nothing new york
slowly hit fetty going to come home no
he has nowhere to throw to and
everybody's safe as a run comes in
bill went for the ball
fetty went for the ball nobody covered
first base there wasn't a play at the
plate
vr on base again mcneal comes home to
make it four nothing runners at the
corners for nimmo nets have scored two
runs in each of the first two innings
and nimo hits one up the middle that's a
base hit and that'll bring it a run
mazika into score vr goes first to third
and the mets are hitting today
nimo's two for two he drives in a run to
make it five to nothing new york
lindor hits it in the air to right field
back goes soto he's got room tagging it
third is vr
soto's got it vr will come home with the
fourth run of the inning and it's six to
nothing new york
lindor with the sacrifice fly his second
rbi of the day alonzo tried to hold and
he stopped it ball four boy
looked like
a very difficult check swing to call
someone
brian wills just ejected somebody in the
nationals dugout and it looks like it's
davey martinez can't walk out there
because he's
in that big cast
and he's going to have to hop his way
out of the dugout and down to the
clubhouse so a uh a painful and uh
short afternoon for davey martinez and
he'll take his exit well even the
sunniest days have some clouds brandon
nemo appeared to hurt himself on that
last
play as he was leaving second and
running hard hoping to score if the odd
was not made at first
and it looked like something might have
grabbed in his hamstring and he is just
beside himself you can see for yourself
folks
right there
right back to strowman checks the runner
gets the out two away
[Applause]
not a lot of net pitchers have had six
nothing leads to work with this year
popped up
and lindor looking through the
sunglasses waiting for it side retired
zika lines one into center field for a
base hit that'll bring home baez and the
mets keep pouring it on mazika with an
rbi single to make it seven to nothing
vr finds the hole again that's seven
straight hits you just can't get him out
four hits in his last four at bats last
night three hits in his first three at
bats today sizzling strowman ready
that's hit sharply lindor with the
backhand flip but it's dropped by vr and
now there's nobody covering third
the throw to strowman and he's out
strowman got there in time to tag out
soto
oh wow what a play but how about baez
with the presence of mind to lead
strowman right to the bag
i have not ever seen a play like that
that is fantastic well michael conforto
will now step in
conforto gets a hold of one deep right
field and that ball is out of here
michael conforto into the second deck
number 11 for conforto
and the mets keep tacking on it's now 9
to nothing
that one's away
faces loaded walk issue to andrew
stevenson and the nationals are on the
board here in the fourth
[Applause]
it was there
driven to center
almora jr under it two runners will tag
another run comes across
escobar to center backs up almora onto
the track
he's got it
at shoulder height another sacrifice fly
garcia comes in
and it's 9-3
flips this o2 pitch into shallow right
center soto coming on
and on a dive he gets there
juan soto lays out for the third out
here in the sixth inning
got a nice read and made a nice play
escobar down the left field line it's
fair
two runs come in so far
bob henley is going to put up the stop
sign for lane thomas a two-run double by
alcides escobar has made it nine to five
in the sixth
soto first pitch hacking ground ball
alonzo to his knees
soto beats it out the ball gets away
from brad hands
coming in as escobar
two runs score
it's a nine seven ball game
now hand behind two and oh
zimmerman grounds to third a chance for
two vr to bias and on to first in time
double play side retired just what the
doctor ordered
with all the whacks beginning to melt
the mitts get the big double play to get
through the inning andrew stevenson has
had himself a nice afternoon walked and
drove in a run in the fourth now the
pitch stevenson swings and tribes at a
deep right center field this is way back
below the wall looking up it is gone
[Applause]
and the nationals have come all the way
back from nine nothing down
it's a nine nine ball game
one two coming from may
struck him out
high heat from trevor may to get gerardo
para for a big second out
oh and one to ruiz
and he popped it up
lindora retreating almora comes in to
call him off and we will go to the ninth
inning trevor may finds his way through
works out of a bases loaded one out jam
this door is driven in two runs in this
game he's two for three with a sacrifice
fly
that's driven in the air that's deep to
right field soto's looking back if it's
fair it's gone it's gone
home run
francisco lindor
towering home run for lindor his 12th of
the year and the mets go in front 11 to
nine in the top of the ninth inning let
the mets off the hook two nights in a
row
again the 1-2 to stevenson
club to center almora is there and the
ball game is over